WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE GOING
TO BE CALLING THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
THAT WE'RE STARTING A BIT LATE.
IT'S ONE OF THE CRAZIER WEEKS OF
THE YEAR HERE IN THE CAPITOL.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
KNOW HOW BUSY EACH OF YOU ARE.
AND DON'T MEAN TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE COMMITTEE BUSINESS PRIOR TO
COMING INTO COMMITTEE. LET'S GO
TO OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM? MAGUIRE.
HERE. MAGUIRE. HERE. GROVE.
GROVE. HERE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HERE. JONES. I'M HERE! JONES.
HERE. LAIRD. HERE LAIRD. HERE.
QUORUM. QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM SECRETARY. TO THOSE
APPOINTEES WHO ARE HERE. THANK
YOU. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS. WE'LL COME
RIGHT BACK TO YOU. THIS SHOULD
TAKE LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO GOVERNOR.
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR IN COMMITTEE TODAY. THIS
IS ITEMS 2D THROUGH I. ITEMS 2D
THROUGH I. IS IT OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR IF WE DO 2D THROUGH J YOU
BETTER BELIEVE IT. 2D THROUGH G
YES. J THERE IS NO J. YEAH YEAH
IT'S D THROUGH I. DO YOU HAVE A
J THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT. WHO
IS THIS. YOU CAN G SHOULD BE I H
I HAVE I GIVE US ONE MOMENT I'M
SORRY. NO NO NO YOU'RE GOOD. YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY DID H DID I
APOLOGIZE? I OKAY. DO YOU WANT
ALL OF IT TOGETHER. ALL RIGHT.
SO, MADAM VICE CHAIR, I
UNDERSTAND THAT'S A MOTION. YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. SO IN FRONT OF US TODAY
IS GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEMS 2D
THROUGH I. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
VICE CHAIR GROVE. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE I MAGUIRE I
GROVE, I GROVE I EGGMAN EGGMAN I
JONES I JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I
FIVE. IT'S A50 VOTE. THAT MOTION
PASSES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO BILL REFERRALS.
WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER THREE,
REFERENCE A BILLS TO COMMITTEES.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MAGUIRE.
AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE. GROVE. GROVE
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
JONES. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT'S FIVE
ZERO. VOTE THAT MOTION PASSES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO SENATE RULE 26. SENATE RULE
26. IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE
? WE HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MAGUIRE.
AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE. GROVE GROVE.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD A LAIRD.
AYE. 5 TO 0. AYE. DANG! LOOK AT
THAT FIVE ZERO VOTE. WE'RE
MOVING RIGHT ALONG. WE'RE NOW
MOVING OVER AGAIN. I THINK,
SENATOR EGGMAN, THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST EXCITING PIECES OF THE
RULE WAIVER REQUEST AGENDA ITEM,
SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO OFFER
THAT MOTION? I MOVE, I LIKE IT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
EGGMAN, MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE. GROVE.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. 5050 VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO FLOOR. ACKNOWLEDGED
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS, IT'S
ITEMS SIX THROUGH TEN. IS THERE
A MOTION TO APPROVE? WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE. GROVE AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD A LAIRD. AYE. 5
TO 0. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S A50 VOTE. THAT MOTION
PASSES. ALL RIGHT, LOOK AT THAT.
WE ARE SET AND READY TO ROLL,
WE'RE GOING TO BE BRINGING UP
FIRST INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO
APPEAR IN FRONT OF COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME MISS
BROOKS. MADAM CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH, MISS BROOKS IS HERE IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE AS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR, HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS, DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. MISS
BROOKS, WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. 1 TO 2
MINUTES. WE'LL GIVE YOU 32ND
PROMPT AS YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT
TWO MINUTES. WELL, THEN YOU CAN
OPEN IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS,
ADVANCE ANY COMMENTS IN YOUR
OPENING. WE WELCOME YOU TO THANK
OR ACKNOWLEDGE ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY BE HERE TODAY IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR WATCHING ONLINE,
AND WE'LL BE KEEPING TIME OF
YOUR OPENING. AGAIN, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I'D FIRST LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MYSELF TO BE CONFIRMED
TODAY AS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS YOU STATED, MY NAME
IS SARAH BROOKS. I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY 80 YEAR OLD
MOTHER, JUDITH BODENHAUSEN,
WHO'S WATCHING VIRTUALLY FROM
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA. TODAY. I
THOUGHT I'D PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND ABOUT MYSELF TO
START. I GREW UP IN OAKLAND,
CALIFORNIA AND ATTENDED SCHOOL
IN BERKELEY, WHICH EXPOSED ME TO
A DIVERSE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
AND IDEAS. I'M A CHILD OF TWO
TEACHERS, A NEW YORKER FROM
CONEY ISLAND, BROOKLYN, AND A
KANSAN FROM TOPEKA. BOTH OF MY
PARENTS WERE POLITICALLY STAUNCH
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAINTAINED A
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE, INCLUDING A
RANGE OF ALL TYPES OF
DEMOGRAPHICS OF PEOPLE. EARLY
ON, I LEARNED THAT PEOPLE ARE
JUST PEOPLE, THAT WE ARE ALL
EQUAL, AND THAT WE ALL SHOULD
TREAT EACH OTHER AS SUCH. I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER BY TRADE. I HAVE
BOTH A BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S
IN SOCIAL WORK. I CARRY THIS
AFFILIATION WITH ME THROUGHOUT
MY PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
LIFE. IT IS THE LENS THROUGH
WHICH I COMMUNICATE, ASSESS AND
EVALUATE ALL THINGS ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS. PLACING CALIFORNIANS
WE SERVE AT THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING DEFINES WHAT I DO AND
WHO I AM. IT IS MY MISSION EVERY
DAY, FROM WHEN I WAKE UP IN THE
MORNING TO WHEN I LAY MY HEAD TO
REST AT NIGHT. IT IS THE DRIVER
OF ALL THAT I DO. I AM THANKFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES IN LIFE
THAT HAVE BROUGHT ME TO WHERE I
AM TODAY. TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY, AND WITH THAT, I'LL
TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU AND
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU, CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR,
THANK YOU. AND I KNOW HOW
PERSONAL THIS IS FOR YOU. AND
WHEN IT'S SO PERSONAL. IT EXUDES
PASSION AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. AND HAPPY
THAT YOU'RE IN STATE SERVICE.
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS, PLEASE. MADAM VICE
CHAIR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR BROOKS, FOR,
TAKING ON THIS HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY, IT IS A HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY, ESPECIALLY WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH THE UNCERTAINTY ON
THE BUDGET, AND THERE ARE CUTS
GOING TO DCS PROGRAMS, AND I
GUESS, IS THERE A WAY THAT THESE
PROGRAMS CAN BE RUN MORE
EFFICIENTLY? SO THAT WE CAN
STILL DELIVER SERVICES TO THOSE
UNDERSERVED INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
UNDER THIS PURVIEW? SURE.
EXCELLENT QUESTION, SENATOR, AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS COMMITTED TO RUNNING OUR
PROGRAMS EFFICIENTLY, AS I
STATED IN MY RESPONSES, ONE SUCH
OPPORTUNITY IS CALAIM CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING
MEDI-CAL, WHICH IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY OUR
BY DCS, IT IS A PROGRAM THAT
OFFERS MANY DIFFERENT OR A
MYRIAD OF DIFFERENT, COMPONENTS.
AND ONE SUCH EXAMPLE IS
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS. AND ENHANCED
CARE MANAGEMENT IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE, THESE ARE TWO NEW
BENEFITS THAT WE'VE BROUGHT IN
THAT PROVIDE, NEW, NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS AND
EFFICIENCIES FOR MEMBERS WITH
RESPECT TO HOW THEY ACCESS
SERVICES. IS THERE, THEY ARE,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS TO, TO
HAVE, EXCUSE ME TO HAVE, TO
HAVE, THE, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS. EXCUSE ME. THAT'S THE
WORD I WAS LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO SERVICES THAT
PROVIDE THEM WITH THINGS THAT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
BEFORE, HAVE ACCESS TO BEFORE,
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
WHILE WE MAY HAVE ADDED NEW
THINGS, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING EFFICIENT NEW
OPPORTUNITIES THAT, THAT, WILL
PROVIDE FOR, I'M GETTING A
LITTLE TONGUE TIED HERE. I DO
APOLOGIZE, SENATOR GROVE. YOU'RE
DOING GREAT. NO, LET ME TAKE A
STEP BACK HERE. I'M GOOD AT
THIS, AND I WILL BE BETTER. SO
HERE WE GO. WE'LL START OVER
AGAIN FOR A MOMENT HERE. OKAY.
SO COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND ECM. I
KNOW THESE OKAY. SO COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS AND ECM ARE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO OUR MEMBERS. AND
ESSENTIALLY VÆ THEY PROVIDE NEW
THINGS SUCH AS HOUSING AND
TENANCY BASED SERVICES FOR OUR
MEMBERS. THESE ARE SERVICES THAT
WEREN'T ALLOWED AND WEREN'T
PROVIDED BEFORE UNDER OUR UNDER
OUR PROGRAM. AND, YOU KNOW,
BEFORE WHEN THOSE SERVICES
WEREN'T PROVIDED, MEMBERS
ESSENTIALLY WERE WERE ACCESSING
SERVICES THAT WERE THE CORE SET
OF SERVICES BUT DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THINGS THAT LOOKED AT
THINGS LIKE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH AND WENT OUTSIDE OF
THE KIND OF CORE SET OF SERVICES
THAT WERE PROVIDED TO THEM. AND
SO WITH THESE NEW SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED TO THEM, I BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE NEW EFFICIENCIES
PROVIDED WITHIN THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. AND ANOTHER
QUESTION I HAVE REGARDING THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM, I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES BECAUSE THE
AREAS THAT I REPRESENTED, THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, WHICH I HAVE A
LARGE HIGH POPULATION OF
MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS AND THE
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENTS RATES
BEING CUT, BEING DELAYED, ALL
THOSE THINGS. I HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS THAT, YOU KNOW,
PROVIDERS WILL NOT STAY IN THAT
FIELD. AND IF THEY DO STAY IN
THAT FIELD, THERE'S JUST
BASICALLY A PATHWAY TO
BANKRUPTCY. I HAVE A LOT OF
PROVIDERS THAT WERE COUNTING ON
THOSE RATES. WHAT'S THIS, HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THE MEDI-CAL,
PROVIDER RATES? BECAUSE IT'S ALL
WELL AND GOOD THAT WE GIVE
SOMEBODY A CARD THAT SAYS YOU'RE
COVERED UNDER MEDI-CAL. BUT IF
YOU CAN'T GET IN TO SEE A DOCTOR
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT TAKING
MEDI-CAL ANYMORE, OR, I MEAN, I
HAD TWO DOCTORS TELL ME THIS
MORNING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
TAKE MEDI-CAL ANYMORE. SO I HAVE
HUGE CONCERNS THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY ON THAT,
THAT LOW SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE PORTION OF OUR
POPULATION. AND I HAVE A LOT OF
THOSE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT,
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. MCFARLAND, SHAFTER, ALL
THE PLACES WHERE A LOT OF OUR
FARMWORKER COMMUNITY WORKS. SO
HOW ARE WE GOING TO ADDRESS
PROVIDER RATES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SUSTAINABLE HEALTH
CARE OR SUSTAINABLE HOSPITALS
AND MEDICAL PROVIDERS THAT WILL
WORK IN THIS SPACE? WELL, I
THINK THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. ONE SUCH THING ARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS. AND SO I
THINK THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THOSE, THOSE ARE PAYMENTS THAT
WE PROVIDE OR DIRECTED PAYMENTS
THAT WE PROVIDE THROUGH OUR
HEALTH PLANS, TO PROVIDERS. AND
THOSE HELP PROVIDE INCREASED
PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS. ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY. AND, YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT, NEGOTIATIONS ARE
ONGOING WITH RESPECT TO THE
BUDGET. BUT SEPARATELY, IN 2024,
WE DID IMPLEMENT THE MCO TAX AND
TARGETED RATE INCREASES WHERE WE
HAD SPECIFIC INCREASES RELATED
TO CERTAIN DIFFERENT AREAS OF IT
WAS SUCH AS SPECIALTY CARE AND
PRIMARY CARE, MATERNAL CARE, SO
WE LOOKED AT THIS, WE LOOKED AT
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WE COULD
TARGET FOR INCREASES WHERE WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE INCREASES
TO PROVIDERS TO, TO SUPPLEMENT
THEIR RATES TO, TO RESPOND TO
YOUR QUESTION. SO ARE YOU SAYING
THAT YOU ACTUALLY PROVIDED THOSE
INCREASES OR THE INCREASES WERE
LISTED? I KNOW WE DID OVER 400
INCREASES AND THERE WERE
INCREASES IN TARGETED RACE ON
NUMBERS, CODE NUMBERS FOR THOSE
RATE INCREASES. BUT THE DELIVERY
OF THOSE RATE INCREASES HASN'T
STOPPED. WE ESTABLISHED THAT IN
COMMITTEE WHEN I SAID, DO YOU
VENMO THEM? DO YOU SEND YOU A
CHECK ANY OPTION OR HOWEVER THEY
RECEIVE THEIR MONEY? THOSE RATE
INCREASES HAVE NOT STARTED BEING
DELIVERED AS PAYMENT YET. THAT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING FOR 2024. THOSE
ARE IN PROCESS AT THIS TIME.
YES. SO THEY HAVE NOT. SO IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START JANUARY
JANUARY AND IT HAS NOT STARTED
AT ALL. THEY SAID THEY'RE GOING
TO BE RETROACTIVE. SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO IS, IS GO BACK AND
JUST VERIFY WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S HAPPENED OR NOT. I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT JUST TO
CONFIRM THAT QUESTION. AND I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IF
THAT'S OKAY. THAT'D BE GREAT
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING, BASED
ON THE COMMITTEE SAID THREE THAT
I SIT ON IS THAT THE RATES WERE
INCREASED ON PAPER, BUT
PROVIDERS ARE NOT GETTING THOSE
RATE INCREASES. BUT WE WERE
GUARANTEED A RETROACTIVE PAYMENT
ONCE THE INCREASES START. SO IF
YOU COULD FOLLOW UP WITH ME, I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. I
WOULD DEFINITELY DO THAT,
SENATOR GROVE, FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS. NØ GREAT QUESTIONS.
AND I APOLOGIZE THAT I GOT A
LITTLE BUMBLED AT THE FRONT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
LET'S GO TO CENTROLEGAL.
FRAWLEY'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MISS BROOKS. NICE TO SEE YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU. AND ALWAYS
NICE TO SEE A FELLOW SOCIAL
WORKER. I WANT TO ASK YOU, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT. YEAH. MORE
PHILOSOPHICAL QUESTIONS. OKAY.
IF I CAN, AND THIS IS JUST ONE
OF MY, MY PET ROADS. I LIKE TO
WANDER DOWN, WHEN I FIRST
STARTED IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
2012, WE GOT RID OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
OKAY SO NOW IT'S JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND IN THE LAST TWO
DECADES, ALMOST SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE A DECADE, I GUESS WE'VE,
WE'VE FOCUSED A LOT MORE ON
MENTAL HEALTH. SO NOW WE HAVE
MADE A LOT OF NEW PROGRAMS JUST
TO DO INITIATIVE OF CAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HANDLE ALL OF THAT OR
DO WE NEED A DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH BACK? I BELIEVE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES CAN HANDLE THAT. I
BELIEVE THAT INTEGRATION IS
BETTER. I DON'T THINK THAT
SEPARATION IS BETTER. I THINK
THAT, HANDLING THINGS AS A
COMPREHENSIVE WHOLE AND ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE THINGS TOGETHER IS
THE BETTER APPROACH. WHEN WE
SEPARATE THINGS, SEPARATE
THINGS, AND WE SILO THINGS AND
THEY'RE NOT WORKING TOGETHER.
PEOPLE TALK LESS, PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS. THE THINGS
AREN'T WORKING TOGETHER. THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T THE HALLWAY
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T HAPPENING.
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN, YOU KNOW,
WITH RESPECT TO WHETHER OR NOT
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING IN CONNECT
, SOMETHING'S HAPPENING IN PROP
ONE THAT NEEDS TO AFFECT
SOMETHING IN THE PHYSICAL HEALTH
WORLD OR VICE VERSA. AND SO I
REALLY THINK THAT DCS CAN HANDLE
IT, TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, AND
THAT IT BELONGS TOGETHER AS ONE.
SO THEN ARE YOU ARGUING FOR SAME
DAY BILLING. THAT'S A TRICK
QUESTION. HEY THAT'S ME. SHE'S
GOT THE MOJO BACK THERE. THERE
YOU GO. YOU KNOW. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY, SO TALK TO ME ABOUT PROP
ONE AND US. RIGHT. SO, I MEAN,
I'VE, I'VE, TALKED TO FRIENDS
WHO I HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS WHO
ARE PRACTITIONERS STILL, AND WHO
SAY, YOU KNOW, I GRITTED MY
TEETH AND YOU WERE DOING IT, SO
I VOTED FOR IT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID THEY'RE GOING
TO LOSE CONTRACTS AS PEOPLE
WERE, AND THEN IN THE NEXT
BREATH, SAY, AND WE CAN BE
BILLING FOR A LOT MORE THAN WE
ARE, WE NEED TO GET OFF OUR
BUTTS AND DO FEE FOR SERVICE.
AND, BILL, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
HELP COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS MAKE
THAT ADJUSTMENT FROM WHAT THEY
WERE USING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DOLLARS FOR, TO HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SHIFT
AND START BILLING AND, AND
RE-ENGINEER THEIR APPROACH.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. I
MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ON THE GROUND. WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE COMMUNICATING.
COMMUNICATION IS GOING TO NEED
TO BE KEY, IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
ABOUT JUST PUTTING OUT PIECES OF
PAPER EITHER. IT'S GOING TO NEED
TO BE ABOUT HAVING CALLS, HAVING
WEBINARS, HAVING MEETINGS,
HAVING A WELL LAYERED AND
OUTLINED, COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY, IF YOU WILL. AND SO I
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
OUR KEY TO ENSURING THAT YOU
FEEL CONFIDENT. YOU CAN'T LET
THIS FAIL. WE CAN'T FAIL, NØ. WE
CANNOT FAIL. THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S IMPORTANT. SO NO, WE CAN'T
FAIL. WHAT'S THE MOST EXCITING
THING YOU'RE GOING TO DO IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS? DO YOU THINK IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT'S A
WELL, THAT'S YOU KNOW, IT GOES
FAST, GIRL. WELL, IT DOES GO
FAST. YOU'RE RIGHT. THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS WAS REALLY FAST,
ACTUALLY, IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
THE TRUTH, THE NEXT FIVE YEARS I
WOULD SAY, THE NEXT, THE MOST
EXCITING THING I THINK, ENSURING
THAT MEMBERS RECEIVE GOOD
QUALITY CARE, THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE MOST EXCITING THING FOR ME.
YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SIR. I'D LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE LOOKING
FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. RIGHT
HEARING SEEING NONE. WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS OPEN IT
UP FOR, PUBLIC TESTIMONY, WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME ALL THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF MISS BROOKS. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME, WE'RE GOING TO
REQUEST THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO 30S. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME. AND IF YOU'RE WITH AN
ORGANIZATION, PLEASE LIST THE
ORGANIZATION. ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHRISTY WEISS WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MISS BROOKS'S APPOINTMENT. YOU
KNOW, IN THE TIME THAT WE'VE HAD
TO WORK WITH SARAH, SHE'S ALWAYS
PROVEN HERSELF TO BE A TRUE
COLLABORATOR, YOU KNOW, A TRUE
PROBLEM SOLVER AND ALWAYS
WILLING TO BE AVAILABLE AND TO
BE ACCESSIBLE. AND THAT'S
REALLY, I THINK, WHAT THOSE OF
US IN THE PROVIDER COMMUNITY
NEED AS WE WORK TO SOLVE THE
MANY COMPLEX CHALLENGES THAT
COME UP WITH THE MANY PROGRAMS
THAT RUN THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
AND MOST OF ALL, I THINK WE ALL
ADMIRE HER DEEP PERSONAL
COMMITMENT TO SERVING MEDI-CAL
MEMBERS AND MAKING SURE THAT
FOLKS THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAN
ACCESS THOSE SERVICES. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
MISS WEISS. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, LINDA
HèA WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY HAVING THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH MISS BROOKS IN
HER PREVIOUS ROLE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT, I HAVE APPRECIATED
HER RESPONSIVENESS, HER IN-DEPTH
KNOWLEDGE OF A VERY COMPLEX
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES COVERAGE
TO OVER A THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS,
AS WELL AS HER, PASSION AND
WELCOME HER RETURN WESTERN
CENTER IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MICHELLE GIBBONS WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY,
SUPERVISOR. EXCUSE ME. I'M GOING
TO MESS THIS UP, BUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. IT'S BEEN A WHILE,
HERE TO SUPPORT MISS BROOKS
CONFIRMATION, I WILL JUST SAY,
AS YOU'VE SEEN DEMONSTRATED
HERE. MISS BROOKS COMES WITH
THIS HONESTY AND A TRANSPARENCY
AND A TRUE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION. WHEN IN DOUBT,
SHE'S ALWAYS HAPPY TO CIRCLE
BACK WITH HER TEAM AND OTHER
MEMBERS AND THEN REALLY BRING
BACK THE ANSWER THAT'S NEEDED.
WE APPRECIATE HER SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP,
WHICH IS NECESSARY AS WE
CONTINUE FROM A COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE TO ENGAGE IN MANY OF
THE INITIATIVES. SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATED AND HERE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, CONNIE DELGADO,
ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM, THESE
ARE THE 33 DISTRICT AND
MUNICIPAL HOSPITALS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MISS BROOKS, WE WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
HERE. HER COMMITMENT TO SERVING
THE MEDI-CAL PATIENTS AND ALL
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO
ALWAYS KEEP A FOCUS ON THE BEST
CARE AND WORKING WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF PROVIDERS IN THIS
STATE AS WE ALL WORK TOWARDS A
COMMON GOAL. SO WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT HER. HER
APPOINTMENT TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HEY, HOW'S IT GOING, KELLY
BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS,
WE'RE THRILLED TO BE HERE TODAY,
TO SUPPORT MISS BROOKS
CONFIRMATION. PUBLIC HOSPITALS
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF WORKING
WITH HER. SHE'S VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND POLICY ORIENTED. SHE KNOWS
THAT STATE POLICY MAKING WILL
IMPACT LOW INCOME FAMILIES,
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ON A PERSONAL
NOTE, I'VE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH TO
WORK WITH HER FOR A DECADE AND A
HALF. SHE'S COLLABORATIVE AND
EVERYTHING YOU COULD ASK FOR IN
A PUBLIC SERVANT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
REBECCA SULLIVAN WITH LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA, WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT
OF SARAH BROOKS TO THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT DHS, NOT ONLY DOES
MISS BROOKS HAVE A LONG HISTORY
AT THE DEPARTMENT, THAT SHE
BRINGS HER EXPERTISE TO, BUT A
PROVEN COMMITMENT TO
COLLABORATION AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT, WHICH IS REALLY
VITAL TO ENSURE THAT WE BUILD
UPON PREVIOUS SUCCESSES AND HAVE
ALL THE RIGHT FOLKS AT THE
TABLE. MISS BROOKS HAS MADE A
HUGE PART IN THE TRANSFORMATION
OF MEDI-CAL OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, AND WE ARE SO
GLAD TO SEE HER SUPPORT
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT AND LEAD
THE WORK BACK AT DHCS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
SHORT REPRESENTING PEACH, THE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
COMMUNITY SAFETY NET HOSPITALS.
WE'RE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MISS BROOKS CONFIRMATION. AS
SENATOR EGGMAN MENTIONED, WE ARE
THRILLED WITH THE HER
COMBINATION OF SOCIAL WORK
SKILLS AND EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE. COUPLED WITH KIND OF
AN UNPARALLELED EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE IN HOSPITAL FINANCING
AND MEDICAID PROGRAMING. WE KNOW
SHE'S GOING TO BE AN AMAZING
CHAMPION WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR OUR SAFETY
NET HOSPITALS, OUR
DISENFRANCHIZED PATIENTS, AND
OUR UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES.
SO WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
HER CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WELCOME HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. EXCUSE ME,
RACHEL BLUCHER I'M ACTUALLY HERE
ON BEHALF OF TWO INDIVIDUAL
MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS, LÀ
CARE AND COMMUNITY HEALTH GROUP.
I WILL ECHO THE SENTIMENTS ON
MISS BROOKS ABILITY TO
COLLABORATE. I THINK
RESPECTFULLY COLLABORATE WITH
THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS THAT SHE
HAS TO DEAL WITH AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I WILL ALSO ADD THAT
SHE IS INCREDIBLY THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION, SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
COLLABORATE AND WORK WITH HER IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. AMMAR RASHID WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
FOR THE ECHO. THE MANY REASONS
THAT WERE LISTED HERE TODAY AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
COLLABORATION TOGETHER AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE MANY PROGRAMS THAT
THE STATE IS WORKING ON IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU, VAL SHEEHAN, CEO, CAL PACE,
THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF
PROGRAMS OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY, WE ARE IN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF MISS
BROOKE'S NOMINATION TO THIS
ROLE, AND WE TOO, FEEL THAT SHE
IS NOT JUST A WONDERFUL
ADVOCATE, BUT A TRUE, A TRULY
COMMITTED, STATE SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE WHO WANTS TO SEE
QUALITY CARE AS WE DO Tê AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH MISS BROOKS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CEO.
APPRECIATE THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME
SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STEP FORWARD AT
THIS TIME, WE'RE GOING TO DO A
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, AND OR
WE'LL OFFER A MOTION, OFFER A
MOTION TO HAVE IT. MISS BROOKS
MOVED TO THE FULL SENATE FLOOR,
SIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
VICE CHAIR. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
VICE CHAIR GROVE AND MISS
BROOKS. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THE
COALITION BEHIND YOU IN SUPPORT
OF YOU. AND I THINK YOU HAVE
SOME OF YOUR TEAM WAS HERE TODAY
AS WELL. WE ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU EACH AND EVERY DAY FOR
WHAT YOU DO FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE STATE AND
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC,
AND SOME OF THE TOUGHEST TIME, I
THINK, THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
I'M GOING TO KNOCK ON WOOD IN
YOUR CAREER. IT'S HOPE. RIGHT,
AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD AYE.
FIVE ZERO. THAT'S A50 VOTE.
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU ARE HEADING
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. APPRECIATE
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK PAUSE TO CHECK IN WITH
MISS LEBLANC. HOW ARE YOU DOING?
GOOD TO GO FOR ANOTHER. THAT'S
GREAT. ALL RIGHT, SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BRING UP MISS
SUNDQUIST. MISS SUNDQUIST, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISS SUNDQUIST IS HERE AS THE
REAL ESTATE COMMISSIONER IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A 32ND PAUSE, GET
HER SET UP, GET HER SOME WATER,
AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU. 30S.
ALL RIGHT, MISS HEDQUIST, WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AND TALK ABOUT WORKING YOUR
WAY THROUGH THE RANKS. IT'S
IMPRESSIVE. WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU UP TO TWO MINUTES
FOR YOUR OPENING TESTIMONY.
DURING THOSE TWO MINUTES, PLEASE
WELCOME ANY FAMILY, FRIENDS THAT
MAY BE WITH YOU HERE IN
COMMITTEE AND OR WATCHING
ONLINE, AND WE'RE GOING TO JUST
ASK, WHEN YOU HEAR A 32ND
PROMPT, JUST KNOW I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE RUDE, BUT I MAY INTERRUPT
WHEN YOU HIT TWO MINUTES,
DIRECTOR SUNDQUIST, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, HONORABLE CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
CONFIRMATION AS REAL ESTATE
COMMISSIONER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE. IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE AND TO WORK WITH MY
FELLOW PUBLIC SERVANTS TO
SUPPORT THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT, TO SAFEGUARD AND
PROMOTE THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
REAL ESTATE MATTERS THROUGH
LICENSURE, REGULATION, EDUCATION
AND ENFORCEMENT. HERE WITH ME
TODAY IS MY SON NOLAN, SITTING
BACK HERE AND, THE AMAZING
LEADERSHIP TEAM FROM DRE
WATCHING ARE MY HUSBAND ERIC, MY
SISTER AYA, MY PARENTS, TATSUO
AND TOMOMI, AND MY FATHER IN
LAW, JOHN. AND THE AMAZING STAFF
FROM DRE. I AM ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL FOR EVERYONE'S SUPPORT
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR ENTRUSTING
ME IN THIS VERY IMPORTANT ROLE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY FROM A
POSITION OF HUMILITY AND PRIDE
FOR BEING THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO BE IN THIS
ROLE. I DON'T TAKE THIS POSITION
LIGHTLY, AND I AM TRULY
COMMITTED TO THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. COMMISSIONER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, AND IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE NOLAN HERE. NICE
TO SEE YOU, NOLAN. THANK YOU.
WHY DON'T WE OPEN IT UP FOR ANY
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS, PLEASE.
SENATOR LEHRER, THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATED READING ABOUT YOU.
YOU YOU HAVE A VERY SCHOOLED
CAREER. THE ONE THING I WAS
GOING TO ASK IS YOU WERE AT THE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION, AND THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY. HOW HOW, DO YOU
GIVEN THE ADVANCES IN TECHNOLOGY
AND ENFORCEMENT, KEEP UP SO THAT
YOU CAN KEEP UP WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU HAVE TO
ENFORCE AGAINST? ABSOLUTELY IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION. AND IT CAN BE
A DIFFICULT THING TO DO BECAUSE
WE ARE DEALING WITH AN INDUSTRY
THAT IS SO CREATIVE AND SO
INNOVATIVE, AND WE ESPECIALLY
SAW THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC. SO
WE TAKE A LOT OF STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE AWARE OF WHAT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE EMERGING WITHIN
THE REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY, SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO LICENSEES AND
IDENTIFY CONSUMER RISKS AND BE
PREVENTIVE AND PROACTIVE WITH
CONSUMERS. FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE
CONSTANTLY MEETING WITH INDUSTRY
MEMBERS TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT
SOFTWARE PROGRAMS THEY'RE USING,
WHAT INNOVATIONS THEY'RE SEEING
IN TECHNOLOGY, AND THEN WE
FOLLOW UP WITH THOSE COMPANIES
THEMSELVES TO MEET WITH THEM, TO
ENGAGE, TO LEARN ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS MODELS AND IDENTIFY ANY
POTENTIAL CONSUMER RISKS OR
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THAT MAY NOT
QUITE FIT WITH THE REAL ESTATE
LAW. AND I AND HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND ENGAGE WITH
THEM, WHEN WE'RE OUT IN THE
FIELD WITH VISITING BROKERS,
WITH OUR ENFORCEMENT STAFF,
THEY'RE ALSO ENGAGING WITH
BROKERS ON INDIVIDUAL BASES TO
DETERMINE WHAT TECHNOLOGIES
THEY'RE SEEING IN THE INDUSTRY,
WHAT NEW SOFTWARE PROGRAMS
THEY'RE SEEING, WHAT CONCERNS
THEY HAVE BECAUSE THEY'RE ALSO
VERY INTERESTED IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION. AND SO HAVING THOSE
ENGAGING CONVERSATIONS, BRINGING
THAT BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE AND THEN LEARNING
ABOUT THOSE AGAIN, GOING BACK TO
THOSE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES AND
LEARNING FROM THEM. SO IT'S A
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT EFFORT FOR
US TO STAY ON TOP OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY AND TECHNOLOGY. SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THAT EDUCATION TO
CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES ALIKE.
WE'VE ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH CAL POLY TO DO A
PROPTECH RESEARCH, I'M SORRY.
THERE'S UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S AN
EXTRA CAL POLY NOW, AND YOU HAVE
TO IDENTIFY WHICH ONE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU'RE PROBABLY
TALKING ABOUT THE CAL POLY, THE
CAL POLY OKAY. SOMEBODY MIGHT
DISAGREE, BUT THAT'S THE
CORRECT. GOTCHA. THANK YOU, THE
CAL POLY WINK, WINK, WE HAD TWO
AMAZING PROFESSORS THAT DID, AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, FIRST OF ITS
KIND, RESEARCH INTO HOW PROPTECH
AFFECTS THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY, OUR LICENSING
POPULATION, CONSUMER PROTECTION,
AND ALSO AFFECTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE. SO IT'S BEEN A
VERY ENGAGING WORK AND VERY
EXCITED. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEE A
COPY OF THAT STUDY, I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE IT TO YOU AS WELL. THANK
YOU. AND YOU PRE-SUPPOSED MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION, WHICH WAS TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE, AND THEN YOU
DID. SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
JUST A COMMENT. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. I READ YOUR
BIO. I LOOKED AT SOME STUFF THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY PUT OUT ONLINE
AND I THINK YOU'RE VERY WELL
QUALIFIED. I TALKED TO MY
REALTORS. THEY LOVE YOU, FROM
ALL PARTS OF THE DISTRICT,
WHETHER IT WAS CURRENT HILLARY
OR FRESNO COUNTIES, SEVERAL OF
THEM WERE LIKE, SHE'S AWESOME.
SHE WORKS WITH US. SHE'S
COLLABORATIVE, AND THEY HAVE A
DEEP RESPECT FOR YOU. SO I'M ALL
IN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR JOHNSON,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I'LL
JUST BE BRIEF AS WELL. YOU SEEM
INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED, AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU. I KNOW
THAT THERE'S, PEOPLE CAN WORK
UNDER A BROKER'S LICENSE, AND I.
AND I WAS BRIEFED ON THERE'S
ONE, LIKE, ONE PER ONE BROKER'S
LICENSE FOR, LIKE, 31,000,
LICENSEES. SO LIKE, IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD, WHICH I'M MORE
USED TO, OR IN THE CLINICAL
FIELD, WE DO OVERSIGHT WITH OUR
LICENSE OF OTHER PEOPLE, BUT
WHAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT IS DONE
THEN FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
LICENSEES? IS IT JUST REVIEW OF
PAPERWORK OR WHAT CAN IT BE?
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW ONE
PERSON DOES 31,000. ABSOLUTELY.
THERE ARE RANGES OF SIZES OF
BROKERAGES WITHIN OUR LICENSEE
POPULATION. THÀNH A VAST
MAJORITY HAVE 0 TO 99
SALESPERSONS WORKING UNDER THEM.
BUT THE REAL ESTATE LAW IS VERY
STRICT ON THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
WHAT REASONABLE SUPERVISION IS
REQUIRED OF A BROKER. AND SO,
OOPS, THERE ARE, REQUIREMENTS TO
HAVE SYSTEMS AND POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TO SUPERVISE ALL OF
THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
HAPPENING UNDER THAT BROKERAGE
TO PROVIDE TRAINING ON FAIR
HOUSING AND BIAS AND IMPLICIT
AND EXPLICIT BIAS, THERE'S A
WHOLE LIST WITHIN OUR
REGULATIONS AND STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. MOST OF THEM ARE
FLYING OUT OF MY BRAIN FOR THE
MOMENT, BUT WE HAVE VERY STRICT
REQUIREMENTS FOR REASONABLE
BROKER SUPERVISION. AND THEN
THERE ARE ALSO ABILITIES FOR A
BROKER TO HAVE DIVISION MANAGERS
AND BRANCH MANAGERS TO ASSIST
WITH THAT SUPERVISION. SO IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ONE PERSON THAT
IS ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
ENGAGING WITH SALESPERSONS. THEY
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO MONITOR
THAT. ALL THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES OF THAT BROKER ARE
BEING FOLLOWED. AND THEN WE AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE,
OBVIOUSLY PROVIDE COMPLIANCE
GUIDES, PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THAT REASONABLE
SUPERVISION SHOULD WORK AND THEN
WORK WITH OUR LICENSEES TO LEARN
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT, THERE
SHOULD BE CHANGES OR WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE APPROPRIATELY
ENFORCING THE LAW. SO THERE'S
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT AND
REEVALUATION OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. AND AS I REVIEWED
THE MATERIALS, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
AMOUNT OF, PEOPLE WITH LICENSE
HAS GONE DOWN, BUT THE AMOUNT OF
SALES HAS GONE UP. HOW DO YOU
ACCOUNT FOR THAT? IS IT
CONCERNING AND IS IT JUST DUE TO
TECHNOLOGY? SURE THE NUMBER OF
NEW LICENSEES COMING IN SEEMS TO
BE DECLINING IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS, BUT OUR RENEWAL RATES
HAVE STAYED AT HISTORIC SAME
LEVELS WHERE AT 76% OF OUR
SALESPERSONS STILL RENEWING AND
94% OF OUR BROKERS STILL
RENEWING. SO WE'RE CAREFULLY
MONITORING OUR LICENSEE
POPULATION, THERE ARE PROBABLY
SOME OUTSIDE INFLUENCES THAT ARE
AFFECTING INTEREST IN THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY. BUT AGAIN,
THOSE WHO ARE IN TEND TO STAY
IN. AND THEN FINALLY, THERE WAS
A IT WAS IN THE NEWS FOR A
WHILE, BUT, PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
GETTING DIFFERENT APPRAISALS ON
THEIR HOUSES. IT HAPPENED WITH
MY FORMER MAYOR, MICHAEL TUBBS
IN STOCKTON. CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT, ABOUT HOW
WE HOW WE MAKE SURE EQUITY
EQUITY IS EQUAL? ABSOLUTELY, I
AM COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING WITH
LICENSEES AND LICENSEES, WORKING
WITH ONE ANOTHER ARE TREATING
EACH OTHER FAIRLY, WE DO A LOT
OF WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT TO
TRAIN OUR STAFF TO PROVIDE
TRAINING TO LICENSEES AND
HOUSING PROVIDERS ON WHAT RIGHTS
THEY SHOULD BE AFFORDING TO THE
CLIENTS THAT THEY WORK WITH, WE
HAVE DONE A LOT OF WORK WITHIN
IMPLEMENTING BILLS THAT REQUIRE
NEW IMPLICIT BIAS, EXPLICIT BIAS
, REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND PRE-LICENSE
EDUCATION. SO ABSOLUTELY, I'M
WITH YOU. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE IS BEING
TREATED FAIRLY. INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS OBVIOUSLY, IS A
COMPONENT OF THAT, BUT WE TRY TO
DO A LOT OF PREVENTIVE AND
PROACTIVE WORK BEFORE ANY
VIOLATIONS OCCUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE.
OUR RESIDENT REALTOR. THANK YOU.
LOOKING AT YOUR LICENSE NUMBER,
YOURS AND MINE ARE FROM SAME ERA
OF THE STATE. MINE MIGHT BE JUST
A LITTLE BIT NEWER THAN YOURS,
BUT THERE'S STILL BOTH LOTS OF
EXPERIENCE BEHIND THOSE NUMBERS.
SO, AND I'M, I'M GOING THROUGH
THE, CONTINUING EDUCATION
PROCESS RIGHT NOW. SO I'M
ACTUALLY IN THE, PROHIBIT
PROBATION PERIOD OF, BEING PAST
MY DUE DATE, BUT I'M NOT I'M NOT
PRACTICING RIGHT NOW. SO WE'RE
ALL GOOD. THIS IS ALL OFF THE
RECORD, BY THE WAY. SO THERE WE
GO. I'VE SAID IT ON THE FLOOR OF
THE SENATE, SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
I'M TRYING TO GET SOMEBODY TO
TAKE THE TEST FOR ME, BUT NO.
ALL RIGHT. SO THAT IS A JOKE.
THAT'S A OH, DEAR LORD, VERY
CLEAR THAT THAT THAT'S A JOKE.
OH I WOULD OPEN ENFORCEMENT
PROCEEDINGS. OKAY. SEE? THERE WE
GO. NICE, NO. WE'RE WHAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK IS, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A RECENT, YOU KNOW,
MAJOR DISRUPTION IN THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA WITH THE
SETTLEMENT THAT NA HAD TO
PARTICIPATE IN, I THINK COR AND
SOME OF THE LOCALS ARE WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THAT WITH HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO REDEFINE A
SELLER'S BROKER VERSUS A BUYER'S
BROKER. I WORKED IN COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE. I DON'T KNOW, I
HAVEN'T PAID AS MUCH ATTENTION
TO THAT CURRENTLY. IF IT'S GOING
TO AFFECT THE COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE MARKET AS MUCH, SO I
GUESS TWO QUESTIONS. DO YOU HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS ON HOW THAT WENT,
HOW IT'S GOING, DOES DRE HAVE A
ROLE IN THAT AS THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE WHATEVER THE
NEW PARAMETERS ARE THAT I GUESS
ARE GOING TO BE FIGURED OUT AS
WE GO OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS OR YEARS. SURE NO DIRECT
COMMENT ON HOW IT'S GOING,
BECAUSE THE LAWSUITS ARE REALLY
SPECIFIC TO THE TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEIR
PRACTICES AND THEIR MEMBERS, AND
THEN THE SYSTEMS THEY USE WITHIN
THAT TRADE ORGANIZATION. SO
ABOUT HALF OF OUR LICENSEES ARE
MEMBERS OF THOSE TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS, AND THE OTHER
HALF ARE NOT, IT IS INTERESTING
TO SEE WHAT'S MOVING FORWARD. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SETTLEMENT
IS KIND OF ON HOLD AS AS THE
SETTLEMENT WAS MOVING FORWARD,
IT WAS MOVING FORWARD ON THE
SELLER'S SIDE LAWSUIT. BUT THEN
THERE'S ALSO A SEPARATE BUYERS
SIDE LAWSUIT WHO'S NOW TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THE SETTLEMENT ON THE
SELLER'S SIDE. SO WE'RE
MONITORING WHAT IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE LAWSUITS WHILE
ALSO MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
MEETING WITH INDUSTRY MEMBERS TO
LEARN WHAT THEY THINK ARE GOING
TO BE CHANGES IN PRACTICE SO
THAT WE CAN LEARN WHAT THOSE
ARE, AND THEN PROVIDE THAT
EDUCATION TO CONSUMERS SO THEY
KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT MOVING
FORWARD. UNFORTUNATELY, THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF CLEAR DIRECTION ON
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
SO I SEE OUR ROLE AS REALLY JUST
MAKING SURE WE'RE AWARE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING, IDENTIFYING
WHAT WHAT POTENTIAL CHANGES IN
PRACTICES WILL BE, HOW THAT KIND
OF INTERPLAYS WITH THE REAL
ESTATE LAW AND THEN BEING
PROACTIVE IN LETTING CONSUMERS
KNOW, HEY, THIS IS HOW IT'S
GOING TO POTENTIALLY LOOK, AND
THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU NEED TO
LOOK OUT FOR. OR HEY, LICENSEE,
I KNOW YOU'RE USED TO DOING
THINGS THIS WAY, BUT THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT MIGHT BE COMING
ABOUT AND HOW YOU SHOULD, MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE STILL COMPLIANT
WITH THE REAL ESTATE LAW AND
TREATING YOUR CONSUMERS AND
CLIENTS FAIRLY. I APPRECIATE YOU
EXPLAINING THAT AFTER HALF YOUR
LICENSEES ARE IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS OR HALF, I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT STATISTIC TO
SHARE, I THINK THE THING THAT I
WOULD BE MOST INTERESTED IN AND,
YOU KNOW, THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN
THESE ASSOCIATIONS IS YOUR
DEPARTMENT. OBVIOUSLY, YOU'RE
PAYING ATTENTION. I APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR EXPLANATION IS VERY
GOOD. IS YOUR STAFF, I MEAN,
THIS COULD HAPPEN QUICKLY.
WHATEVER THE CHANGES ARE GOING
TO BE, OR IT COULD BE DRAWN OUT,
AS YOU SAID, WITH THESE OTHER
CASES, WHO KNOWS HOW LONG IT
COULD BE DRAWN OUT FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME AND THEN HAPPEN QUICKLY.
IS YOUR STAFF READY FOR THAT TO
REACT AND BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
TO THE, CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE LICENSEES WHEN THEY NEED
SOMETHING TO HAPPEN? YOU GUYS
ARE READY TO GO. YOU'RE PREPARED
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO BE NIMBLE
WHEN THAT TIME COMES.
ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE PROJECT
PLANS IN PLACE. WE HAVE
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP AND THEN
MANAGEMENT AND STAFF WORKING TO
IDENTIFY ALL THOSE KEY AREAS AND
KEY COMPONENTS AND HAVE
ADVISORIES READY, HAVE THINGS
READY TO GO. ON THE FLIP OF A
SWITCH. GREAT. AND I'LL JUST,
YOU KNOW, MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
DRES HAS ALWAYS BEEN VERY GOOD.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, WHEN I
TOOK MY FIRST TEST, HOWEVER MANY
LONG, TWO DECADES AGO, WHATEVER
IT WAS, UP UNTIL MOST RECENTLY,
THE ASSOCIATIONS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY HAVE INVITED YOUR STAFF.
THE COMMISSIONERS COME DOWN IN
THE PAST TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
EVENTS, AND IT'S ALWAYS BEEN,
VERY PROFESSIONAL AND VERY WELL
DONE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP
THAT UP. ALL THAT TO SAY, I HOPE
YOU KEEP THAT UP. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS DISCUSSION,
HEARING SEEING NONE FROM
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN PUBLIC COMMENT, WE'RE GOING
TO WELCOME FOLKS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE PODIUM. IF
YOU DON'T MIND PROVIDING YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME. IF YOU'RE
WITH AN ORGANIZATION, IF YOU
COULD PLEASE PROVIDE THE
ORGANIZATION'S NAME. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU. YOU HAVE 30S. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. VERY
NICE TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING US, JENNIFER
SVEC, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS, WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACTUALLY ECHO SENATOR GROVE'S
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO THE
ACCESS AND ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PENDING
APPOINTMENT OF COMMISSIONER
SUNDQUIST. WE'VE HAD AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS, ESPECIALLY IN HER
CURRENT ROLE, TO BE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE WITH HER, HER AND
HER STAFF TO ADDRESS A VARIETY
OF MARKET CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING. ADDITIONALLY, IN HER
PRIOR SERVICE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE AS THE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION DIVISION
HEAD, SHE'S ALWAYS BEEN
EXTREMELY ACCESSIBLE TO OUR
MEMBERS, PARTICIPATED IN OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEETINGS,
OFFERED INSIGHTS AND INFORMATION
, AND BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
RESPONSIVE WHEN WE'VE ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT EITHER
ENFORCEMENT OR OTHER ISSUES THAT
SHE COULD BE OF ASSISTANCE WITH.
SO HER LONGEVITY WITH THE
ORGANIZATION WITHIN STATE
SERVICE HAS BEEN OF EXTREME HELP
TO US. IT IS ALSO HELPING US GO
FORWARD AS WE NAVIGATE THE
COMPLICATED WORLD THAT'S COMING
FORWARD WITH US, WITH NEW
NEGOTIATIONS, CONVERSATIONS, AS
WELL AS TRANSPARENCY.
TRANSPARENCY IS NOT JUST
IMPORTANT IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, BUT IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT WITHIN THE REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTION PROCESS. AND THAT
GOES TO ALL OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY BY THE SENATORS TODAY. I
WOULD ALSO PERSONALLY LIKE TO
MAKE MYSELF AVAILABLE TO ASSIST
WITH ANY QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT
TO REAL ESTATE, SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FROM THE GROUND LEVEL,
ESPECIALLY AS IT COMES TO LARGE
BROKER SUPERVISION AND HOW THE
OFFICE MANAGER PROVISIONS WORK
WITHIN THE STATE LAW. IN
PRACTICAL APPLICATION. AS
MINORITY LEADER JONES ALSO
HAPPEN TO MEET WITH YOU TO
DISCUSS WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN
THE NEWS BETWEEN NAR AND
CALIFORNIA. BUT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE CALIFORNIA IS
DIFFERENT THAN EVERY OTHER
STATE. I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO OUR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND CAN
TELL YOU THAT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA FAR
AND AWAY EXCEED ANY OTHER STATE.
AND WE ARE PROUD OF THAT FACT.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
ASSISTANCE. VERY GRATEFUL. GOOD
TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WELCOME MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MIKE BULLERT, SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE ASSOCIATION. OUR
INTERSECTION WITH MISS SUNDQUIST
OVER THE YEARS HAS BEEN THROUGH
THE MORTGAGE LENDING REGULATION
ACTIVITIES OF THE DEPARTMENT.
AND TO BE FRANK, THAT IS A SMALL
BUT CRITICAL ELEMENT OF DREY'S
MISSION. AND TO BE MORE FRANK,
PROBABLY TAKES A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
RESOURCES. MORTGAGE BROKERING IS
A HIGH DOLLAR, A VERY SENSITIVE
ACTIVITY. AND WE HAVE OVER THE
YEARS FOUND DRE AND MISS
SUNDQUIST THROUGH HER LEADERSHIP
TO BE TOUGH BUT FAIR,
ACCESSIBLE, FOCUSED ON EDUCATION
AND PREVENTION, THÀNH AND ALWAYS
WILLING TO COLLABORATE WITH US
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
HARMED THROUGH THE MORTGAGE
LENDING PROCESS BY MORTGAGE
BROKERS. I HOPE NOT BY OUR
MEMBERS, BUT IT CAN HAPPEN. AND
WE JUST COULD NOT BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF HER LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS. IT'S
IMPORTANT. AND SHE'S DONE A FINE
JOB. SHE'LL MAKE A TERRIFIC
COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO COME UP
AND SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STEP FORWARD TO THE PODIUM
SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO ASK FOR THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. WE'RE GOING
TO DO A LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION
HEARING AND SEEING NO ONE RISE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY LAST
MINUTE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE'LL ALSO SEE IF THERE'S A
MOTION, SO MOVED. I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE COMPANY TO THE FULL
SENATE FLOOR FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL. LET'S GO TO
OUR SECRETARY. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE GROVE. GROVE.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE 5
TO 0. THAT'S A50 VOTE.
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU'RE HEADING
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM COMMISSIONER. AND
I'M SURE YOUR PARENTS ARE SO
INCREDIBLY PROUD. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A 62ND BREAK. WE'RE
GOING TO LET MISS LEBLANC JUST
CHILL FOR A SECOND, IF THAT'S
ALL RIGHT. IN THE MEANTIME,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MR. MCGUIRE.
YOU'RE MISSING THE C IN THE
NAME, THERE WE GO. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE YOU COME ON FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO DO OUR SWITCH OUT
AND THEN WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU IN 60S.
THE. BRINGING IT BACK HERE. AND
HAVE OUR FINAL APPOINTEE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE ARE GOING
TO WELCOME MR. MCGUIRE TO
COMMITTEE. MOVING FORWARD AS A
MEMBER OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. MR.
MCGUIRE, YOU'LL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOUR OPENING REMARKS. AND WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY DURING YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. PLEASE WELCOME
ANY FRIENDS FAMILY THAT ARE
EITHER HERE IN PERSON OR
WATCHING ONLINE AND OF COURSE,
WE'LL GIVE YOU A 32ND PROMPT AS
YOU GET CLOSE TO THE TWO
MINUTES. MEMBER MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GRATEFUL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. AND
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY FOR
CONSIDERATION OF MY CONFIRMATION
OF REAPPOINTMENT TO THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
I'VE WORKED MY ENTIRE CAREER AS
A PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER TO
ADVANCE WATER SOLUTIONS THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY, ITS PEOPLE, AND ITS
ECOSYSTEM. AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M GREATLY HONORED AND THANKFUL
TO THE GOVERNOR FOR MY
REAPPOINTMENT. AND ALTHOUGH THEY
AREN'T ABLE TO ATTEND IN PERSON
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK MY WIFE,
THREE SONS AND PARENTS WHO HAVE
ALL SUPPORTED ME CONSISTENTLY
THROUGH THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING ON THE BOARD. LOOKING TO
THE FUTURE, I'M EXCITED FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE MY
SERVICE BECAUSE I FEEL WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS TO ADDRESS THE
ADMITTEDLY IMMENSE WATER
CHALLENGES WE FACE, SUCH AS
ENSURING SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
ALL, ACHIEVING SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER, AND MITIGATING
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS. AND ONE
OF THE ENGINEERS SEATS ON THE
BOARD. I STRIVE TO BRING
TECHNICAL AND PRACTICAL
PERSPECTIVES TO THE TOUGH
DECISIONS THAT WE FACE. I ALSO
BELIEVE THE BOARD PROVIDES AN
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT FORUM FOR
THE PUBLIC AND OTHER INTERESTED
PARTIES TO WEIGH IN ON CRITICAL
WATER ISSUES, AND I WORK EVERY
DAY TO LISTEN AND LEARN WITH AN
OPEN MIND. AND WITH THAT, I
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. BOARD MEMBER. WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH MR. LAIRD AND LOOK TO THE
REST AND, MADAM VICE CHAIR, MR.
LAIRD, FIRST, THANKS FOR THE,
HELPFUL MEETING. AND I DID
COMMENT DURING THAT MEETING THAT
IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE THAT THE
ENGINEERS SEAT THAT YOU OCCUPY
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN TOUGH TO
FILL WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
OPERATIONAL. AND YOU HAVE BEEN
AND I SALUTE YOU, FOR THAT, I
WANTED TO ASK ABOUT TWO SUBJECTS
WE TALKED ABOUT IN. THE FIRST
ONE IS THE SAFE DRINKING WATER,
BECAUSE WHEN THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM GOT TRANSFERRED
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH OVER TO THE
WATER BOARD, I THINK THERE WERE
1.6 MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE WATER BOARD HAS WORKED
TO REDUCE THAT BY 600,000. SO
IT'S A MILLION. BUT NOW IT'S
TOUGHER. THE EASIER ONES WERE
DEALT WITH AND NOW IT'S TOUGHER.
WHAT SORT OF AS A MEMBER OF THAT
TEAM ARE YOUR PLANS TO TRY TO
ATTACK THE REMAINING PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER?
WELL, YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. TEN YEARS AGO, THIS
WAS NEW TO THE WATER BOARD. WE
DIDN'T HAVE A DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM. AND IN MANY RESPECTS,
WE'RE STARTING FROM THE GROUND
FLOOR, WITHIN OUR ORGANIZATION.
SO I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE, AND IN
NO SMALL THANKS TO SB 200 AND
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER, ACT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT THAT NEED. WE'RE NOW
FIVE YEARS INTO THAT PROGRAM.
AND AS YOU SAY, HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO HELP, OVER 600,000
CALIFORNIANS GET ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER, YOU'RE ALSO
RIGHT IN POINTING OUT THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES AHEAD
OF US, WE HAVE 3000 PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA, 3000. AND
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE
VERY SMALL, LESS THAN 500
CONNECTIONS. AND YET EACH ONE
HAS ITS OWN CHALLENGES, ITS OWN
UNIQUE WATER SUPPLY CHALLENGES,
ITS OWN MANAGEMENT. AND MANY
BOARDS AND COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
EACH HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS AND ARE
DESERVING OF SAFE DRINKING WATER
, WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT WE'RE
MAKING INCREDIBLE PROGRESS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT, OVER
100 WATER SYSTEM CONSOLIDATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA IN RECENT YEARS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH,
NEARLY 400 OF THOSE WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE ON THE, THE
FAILING OR AT RISK, LEVEL. SO
YOU'RE RIGHT. I CAN'T SNAP MY
FINGERS AND, YOU KNOW,
OVERNIGHT, ENSURE THAT EACH OF
THESE SYSTEMS, ALTHOUGH VERY
DESERVEDLY, SHOULD HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER IMMEDIATELY HAVE
THAT. BUT A LOT OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN
PLACE, SUCH AS AN EXPEDITED
DRINKING WATER GRANT PROGRAM AND
OTHER MEASURES I FEEL ARE KIND
OF FLY WHEELING AND ACCELERATING
OUR ABILITY TO MOVE THESE
PROJECTS FORWARD MORE QUICKLY.
WELL, I KNOW WE TALKED AND IT I
GET GRATUITOUS. WE CAN SAY THAT
I HAVE A BILL TO TRY TO DO
MINIMUM STANDARDS OF
ADMINISTRATION, ABILITY FOR
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS, BUT NOT A
WATER SYSTEM IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW.
THEY JUST DIDN'T KNOW BASIC
THINGS. THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHO THEIR CUSTOMERS WERE. THEY
DIDN'T HAVE AN UP TO DATE LIST.
AND THERE WERE THINGS THAT MADE
IT REALLY HARD TO TRY TO HELP.
AFTER A FIRE DESTROYED PART OF
IT AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE SORT OF TUNED IN TO THAT.
I IF I COULD JUST ADD. SO, YES,
I WOULD AGREE THAT HAVING
APPROPRIATE TECH, TECHNICAL,
MANAGERIAL AND FINANCIAL,
FUNDAMENTALS IN PLACE FOR WATER
SYSTEMS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE ONE THING WE WANT TO
DO IS GET THESE SYSTEMS OFF THE
LIST, GET THEM TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER, AND THEN IMPORTANTLY,
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T COME BACK
ON THE LIST EVER AGAIN. AND I
THINK IT'S THOSE SORT OF
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE GOING TO
HELP DO THAT. AND I HEAR STORIES
LIKE THE ONE YOU JUST SHARED ALL
THE TIME, ABOUT SYSTEMS ALL
AROUND THE STATE THAT HAVE
SIMILAR STRUGGLES. AND WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THAT HAPPENED. IT
WAS THE STATE THAT HAD TO COME
IN WITH HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS AND TRY TO PROTECT THE
DRINKING WATER WHEN THEY FAILED
THE BASIC ABILITY TO DO IT. THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT IS WATER RECYCLING AND THE
REASON I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT IT
IS IT'S ABOUT THE ONLY UNIQUE
WATER SOURCE THAT APPLIES TO
ALMOST ANY WATER DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. WHILE THEY STRUGGLE
FOR SURFACE STORAGE OR
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT. AND I
KNOW THE WATER BOARD ADMINISTERS
THE REVOLVING LOAN PROGRAM. AND
WHEN IT WAS IN THE WATER BOND
TEN YEARS AGO, IT WAS THE ONE
POT THAT WAS SUBSCRIBED. AND
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY. AND HOW DO
YOU TRY TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL NEED OR THE FACT THAT
THAT THERE'S A NEED THERE, THAT
WE JUST DON'T SEEM TO BE MEETING
WHEN IT'S THE ONLY WATER SUPPLY
AVAILABLE TO SOME NEW WATER
SUPPLY AVAILABLE TO SOME AREAS?
WELL, THIS IS WHERE I GET
EXCITED AS AN ENGINEER, BECAUSE
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING AT NEW
SOURCES OF SUPPLY AND SOLUTIONS.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S WATER
SUPPLY STRATEGY WHEN IT COMES TO
RECYCLED WATER REALLY SPEAKS TO
THIS, AND THAT'S FAIRLY
AMBITIOUS. GOALS, LOOKING TO
HAVE 800,000 ACRE FEET OF
RECYCLED WATER BY 2030 AND 1.8
MILLION OF ACRE ACRE FEET OF
RECYCLED WATER BY 2040. AND HOW
WE GET THERE, DOES NOT COME
CHEAP, AND DOES NOT COME WITHOUT
INNOVATION. AND THE WILLINGNESS
TO REALLY INVEST IN OUR FUTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE'RE SEEING
THAT. I THINK YOU LOOK UP AND
DOWN THE COAST TO MANY
COMMUNITIES IN YOUR, DISTRICT, I
WOULD SAY SOQUEL CREEK WATER
DISTRICT, MONTEREY, MORRO BAY,
THERE'S MANY THAT ARE REALLY
LEANING IN TO RECYCLED WATER AND
LOOKING AT REUSE AS THE FUTURE
OF WATER SUPPLY RESILIENCY,
WHERE THEY HAVE THOSE RESOURCES,
SO I THINK OUR, OUR JOB AT THE
WATER BOARD IS TO HELP TELL THAT
STORY ABOUT WHAT WHAT THAT
OPPORTUNITY IS, WHAT THE FUTURE
OF WATER CAN BE WHEN IT COMES TO
REUSE, AND IDENTIFY THOSE NEEDS.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
OF DOING A WASTEWATER NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, AROUND FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE, WHICH IS FOCUSED
ON WASTEWATER COLLECTION AND
TREATMENT. BUT I THINK ALSO HELP
IDENTIFY WHERE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL REUSE OPPORTUNITIES.
AND WE, WE ARE JUST I THINK I
JUST LOOK FORWARD TO THIS, THIS,
THIS COMING DECADE AS WE'RE ABLE
TO HELP. HOPEFULLY ARTICULATE
BETTER AND ACHIEVE SOME OF THE
LOFTY GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SET.
WELL, THANK YOU. AND I SHOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE MORRO BAY ONE
WAS CONTENTIOUS AND IT OPENED
THREE WEEKS BEFORE THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS AND
TRANSFERRED. AND IF IT HADN'T,
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE RIGHT INTO
THE OCEAN IN THOSE ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS AND THE WATER BOARD BEING
WILLING TO HELP MOVE THAT ALONG
WAS A KEY PARTNER IN THAT
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE NOT
HAPPENING. SO THANK YOU. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. LAIRD. LET'S GO TO VICE
CHAIR GROUP. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, THANK YOU, MR,
COMMISSIONER MAGUIRE, FOR OR
BOARD MEMBER I APOLOGIZE,
MAGUIRE, FOR, MEETING WITH ME
AND SPENDING THE TIME WITH ME
THAT YOU DID. I MEAN, WE HAD A
LOT OF DIFFERENT DISCUSSIONS AND
OBVIOUSLY REPRESENTING THE TOP
THREE FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD, WATER IS VERY
IMPORTANT, TO MY DISTRICT. THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
AROUND THE KING'S RIVER.
SITUATION THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
APPLICATIONS AND PERMISSIONS
PROCESS RELATED TO WATER
DIVERSIONS ALONG THE KINGS RIVER
AND NOW THE RIVER. THE RIVER
DESIGNATED POINTS FOR DIVERSION,
WHETHER IT'S UPPER RIVER, WHICH
IS ARE ALL MAN MADE DIVERSIONS
OR THE LOWER PART OF THE RIVER,
WHAT'S THE BOARD'S PROCESS FOR
APPROVING DIVERSION APPLICATIONS
AND APPROVING REQUESTS FOR
DIVERSION CHANGES? SO ONE THING
I WANT TO SAY SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION, BY
THE WAY. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
KINGS RIVER, THERE ARE A LOT OF
INTERESTS IN THAT RIVER, IN THE
RESOURCES THAT IT PROVIDES.
CERTAINLY. AND BECAUSE OF THAT,
THERE IS ACTUALLY A HEARING
PROCESS UNDERWAY BEFORE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD'S ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE RIGHT NOW TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE IS AND TO WHAT
EXTENT THERE IS WATER AVAILABLE
IN THAT RIVER SYSTEM. SO BECAUSE
OF THAT, I AM, PROHIBITED FROM
SPEAKING MORE AS IT RELATES TO
THAT HEARING PROCESS, BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO JUST WATER, RIGHT?
APPLICATIONS IN GENERAL AND
CHANGE PETITIONS THAT YOU ASKED
ABOUT, WE DO HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE AND A
VERY WILLING AND HELPFUL STAFF
THAT I'M SURE WOULD BE WE COULD
CONNECT YOU WITH, IF INTERESTED,
TO FIND OUT MORE ABOUT WHAT THAT
PROCESS WOULD ENTAIL. I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND I UNDERSTAND. I TOTALLY
GET IT. IT'S IN A HEARING
PROCESS AND WE'RE LITIGATION
HEARING PROCESS OR WHATEVER NOW.
AND SO I GET THAT WE NEED TO
WAIT FOR THE OUTCOME ON THE,
SIGMA, THE SELF-CONTAINED GROUND
OR SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT. I FEEL LIKE IT'S
ENTERING A NEW STAGE, YOU KNOW,
INDIVIDUALS HAD TO COME TOGETHER
IN THE LOCAL LEVEL, BUT WE DO
HAVE, BASINS THAT ARE NOW BEING,
I DON'T WANT TO SAY TAKEN OVER
BY THE BOARD, BUT GOING INTO
PROBATION. PROBATION WITH THE
BOARD, WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE FOR THE STATE
WATER BOARD IN THIS NEW ROLE TO
BRING LOCAL CONTROL IF THEY
CAN'T MANAGE IT THEMSELVES INTO
THE PURVIEW OF WHICH YOU SIT ON?
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. IT'S A TOUGH ONE. IT'S
ONE I'VE BEEN WRESTLING WITH FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. I THINK
THE INTENT OF THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT HAS
BEEN CLEAR ALL ALONG, WHICH IS
IT'S THE DESIRE FOR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY. YEAH,
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES TO MANAGE THEMSELVES
AND FIND PATHWAYS, MEANINGFUL
PATHWAYS TO SUSTAINABILITY. BY
2040, I DIDN'T WISH ANY OF THESE
BASINS TO COME TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD. WE DO HAVE SIX
BASINS THAT ARE UNDER,
POTENTIALLY UNDER CONSIDERATION
FOR PROBATION, THE FIRST ONE WE
DID VOTE ON HERE RECENTLY, BUT
WHETHER A BASIN IS IN PROBATION,
BEFORE THE STATE BOARD OR,
CURRENTLY OR, BEING CONSIDERED
FOR POTENTIAL PROBATIONARY
ACTION, THE WHOLE POINT IS TO
GET THEM OUT OF THAT PROCESS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THAT IS MY
GOAL. I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
MEETING WITH THOSE VERY AFFECTED
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES TO TRY AND WORK THROUGH
AND IDENTIFY PATHWAYS TO MOVE
THEM OUT OF PROBATION, IDEALLY
BEFORE FOR A HEARING MIGHT BE
NEEDED. BUT EVEN FOR THE ONE
THAT WE DID HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ON, HERE IN LAST IN
APRIL. Ã PROBATION IS NOT A
STATE TAKEOVER OF GROUNDWATER IN
THAT BASIN. IT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE. IT'S A ONE YEAR
TIMELINE, TO FIX THEIR PLAN, TO
FIX THE ISSUES THAT WERE FOUND
IN THEIR PLAN AND TO GET, GET
THEM BACK UNDER LOCAL CONTROL.
SO I'M HOPEFUL. I'M GOING TO BE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT END. AND,
FINGERS CROSSED THAT'S WHERE WE
END UP HERE WITH ALL THESE
BASINS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE, I HAVE A LOT OF
FARMERS IN THAT AREA THAT ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
BEING ABLE TO GROW FOOD BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO HAVE WATER TO DO SO
IF A NUMBER OF SMALL FARMERS IN
THE TULARE LAKE SUB-BASIN, WHICH
IS THE ONE THAT WAS VOTED ON AND
NOW ON PROBATION, AND THEY'RE
EXTREMELY FEARFUL, FEARFUL THAT
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A PATH
FORWARD FOR THEM. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE.
EXPLAINING THAT IT IS JUST A ONE
YEAR PROBATION AND THAT IT'S NOT
A STATE TAKEOVER, AND YOUR
ACTUAL GOAL IS TO RETURN IT BACK
TO THEM AFTER YOU FIX THE ISSUE
SO THAT EVERYBODY HAS ADEQUATE,
ACCESS TO WATER. ABSOLUTELY. IT
IS GOING TO TAKE, ALL HANDS ON
DECK. SO IT IS GOING TO TAKE
PARTICIPATION FROM THOSE
AGENCIES, FROM THE LOCALS, TO,
TO REALLY IDENTIFY AND CORRECT
THOSE ISSUES WITH THE PLAN AND
GET THEM BACK IN, WHERE IT
BELONGS. I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
I WANT TO ASK YOU. ACTUALLY, I
HAVE TWO, BUT I PROBABLY WILL
GET IN TROUBLE FOR ASKING YOU
THE SECOND ONE, IN YOUR OPINION,
SHOULD GSA'S STOP EXPORTING
WATER, FOR PROFIT? I MEAN, JUST
A LARGE FARMERS HAVE LARGE
AMOUNTS OF WATER, AND THEY
EXPORT THAT WATER FOR PROFIT
INSTEAD OF USING IT WITHIN THE
GSA, COMMUNITY THAT THEY'RE IN.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT, OR
CAN YOU EVEN ANSWER IT? WELL, SO
WHAT WHAT I WILL SAY IS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW THE RULES. I
THINK THERE'S MULTIPLE LEVELS OF
JURISDICTIONAL OVERSIGHT HERE.
COUNTIES CAN CERTAINLY HAVE,
ORDINANCES IN TERMS OF WATER
EXPORTS AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ACTIONS. I HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
GROUNDWATER AGENCIES COMPLY WITH
STATE LAWS AND REGULATIONS. SO
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE, YOU KNOW, I PERHAPS DON'T
HAVE AS MUCH OF A DIRECT OPINION
ON WHETHER IT SHOULD OR
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN SO MUCH AS WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ANY MOVEMENT
OF WATER FOLLOWS ALL OF THE
RULES THAT DO EXIST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SIR, VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR. MR.
MCGUIRE, WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO MR. JONES. THANK YOU,
MR. MCGUIRE OR MR. CHAIR? MR.
MCGUIRE. THE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN SOME
CONCERNS, AND MAYBE SOME HISTORY
, PARTICULARLY REGARDING SAN
DIEGO. I HAVE NOT BEEN A BIG FAN
OF THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD IN SAN
DIEGO. AND I WILL ADMIT TODAY
THAT, MANY OF MY CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES WITH THEM ARE, MAYBE
OLD BECAUSE I HAVEN'T REALLY
HEARD MUCH RECENTLY, BUT, THERE
SEEMS TO BE A SENSE THAT THEY'RE
NOT RESPONSIVE. TO THE COMMUNITY
WHEN THERE ARE PROBLEMS, THEY'RE
OVER ENFORCING. WHEN THERE IS A
VIOLATION. I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
DEPUTIZING OR REQUIRING THE
CITIES TO, DO THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT AND DO THEIR JOB,
BUT I THINK THE THINGS THAT THAT
ARE MOST DISTURBING TO ME ABOUT
IT AND AGAIN, I WILL ADMIT THAT
THESE, THESE COMPLAINTS HAVE GOT
SOME YEARS BEHIND THEM. SO MAYBE
THINGS HAVE CHANGED AND THEY'RE
BETTER NOW. BUT, WHEN DEVELOPERS
OR LAND USERS WERE FINED FOR
RUNOFF, OF WHATEVER KIND, AND
WERE GIVEN A CITATION, THE BOARD
WASN'T VERY RESPONSIVE IN
ALLOWING IN THE APPEAL PROCESS
OR WHEN THEY SOMEBODY WAS COMING
TO THE BOARD MEETING TO PRESENT
THEIR CASE, THE BOARD WOULDN'T
HAVE A QUORUM SO THAT THEY WOULD
GET THEY WOULD GET PUT OFF FOR
ANOTHER 3 OR 4 MONTHS UNTIL
THERE COULD BE A QUORUM, SO I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE ISSUES. IS
THAT NEWS TO YOU? AND DO I NEED
TO DO SOME MORE RESEARCH TO COME
BACK WITH SOME MORE CURRENT
INFORMATION? I WOULD LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT. TO
GET A LITTLE BIT BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING CURRENTLY. OKAY. I
CERTAINLY I THINK EVERYTHING I
SAID IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT, AND I
WOULD ADD RESPONSIVE AND
CUSTOMER SERVICE BASED, IN MY
VIEW, APPLIES TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND SHOULD ALSO APPLY TO
THE REGIONAL BOARDS, I HAVEN'T
HEARD A WHOLE LOT OF THOSE TYPES
OF VIEWS RECENTLY, BUT HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND I'LL
FOLLOW UP TO AND DO SOME
RESEARCH ON MY OWN WITH SOME OF
MY CONSTITUENTS BACK IN THE
DISTRICT, ONE THING THAT IS
COMING UP IS THERE'S A NEW
REGULATION REGARDING NITROGEN.
AND I THINK AS RUNOFF AND
GROUNDWATER IN SAN DIEGO, OUR
FARMS ARE, YOU KNOW,
CONSIDERABLY DIFFERENT THAN I
THINK MOST OF THE REST OF THE
STATE. OUR AVERAGE FARM SIZE IS
FOUR ACRES, WHICH I THINK MOST
FARMS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
OTHER THE COASTAL AREA, THEIR
DRIVEWAYS ARE FOUR ACRES. SO SAN
DIEGO IS VERY UNIQUE IN THAT THE
NHÀ AND A LOT OF OUR FARMS ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUBURBAN AREAS OR
THE INTERFACE BETWEEN SUBURBAN
AND RURAL AREAS. SO THERE'S SOME
CONCERN IN SAN DIEGO THAT THIS
NITROGEN REGULATION IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE OVER RESTRICTIVE
AND, AND CAUSE MORE PAPERWORK,
BASICALLY UNNECESSARY PAPERWORK
ON THE SIDE OF THE FARMERS THAN
REALLY IS GOING TO SOLVE ANY
PROBLEM THAT'S BEING PRESENTED.
ARE YOU ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT AT
ALL A LITTLE BIT? OKAY, SO FOR
ONE, THE STATE WATER BOARD
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT, AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE, OF THE NINE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARDS. SO WHAT CAN HAPPEN IS
WHEN A REGIONAL BOARD HAS A
PERMIT, MAKES A DECISION THAT
CAN BE PETITIONED FOR REVIEW BY
THE STATE BOARD. SO WHAT I DON'T
REALLY WANT TO DO IS STEP IN AND
OPINE ABOUT THEIR PERMIT. THAT'S
BEFORE THEM RIGHT AT THE MOMENT,
BUT I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
NITROGEN MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES,
AND THE UNIQUENESS OF
AGRICULTURE AROUND THE STATE. I
AGREE WITH YOU. IT IS WIDE AND
VARIED. THERE IS LOTS OF
DIFFERENT TYPES AND SIZES OF
FARMS AROUND THE STATE, AND
THERE SHOULD BE RULES IN PLACE
THAT REFLECT THOSE DIFFERENCES,
SO WE'RE, WE'VE TACKLED THESE
ISSUES IN THE CENTRAL COAST
REGION, AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REGION. AND THE REASON I
BELIEVE THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL
BOARD HAS A PERMIT AMENDMENT
MOVING FORWARD IS BECAUSE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ORDER FROM THE
STATE BOARD IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REGION. RIGHT. WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW OF
CONVENING AN EXPERT PANEL AND
INDEPENDENT EXPERT PANEL TO
WEIGH IN ON EXACTLY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU BRING UP,
INCLUDING, WHAT TYPES OF
NITROGEN MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
WOULD MAKE THE MOST SENSE FOR
SMALLER FARMS? SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING UP THE AND THAT'S
ALSO IN MY NOTES. SO REGARDING
THE EXPERT PANEL, DO YOU THINK
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT REPRESENTATION FROM
ALL THE WATER REGIONS TO BE ABLE
TO GET A WELL-ROUNDED
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT THOSE
ANSWERS ARE GOING TO BE? YES.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO ME, WE
ARE CONTRACTING WITH SACRAMENTO
STATE TO HIRE AND RETAIN THE
EXPERT PANEL. SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE IS SOME INDEPENDENCE
THERE. BUT WE'RE SOLICITING
STATEWIDE FOR EXPERTS THAT CAN
BRING THIS TYPE OF KNOWLEDGE TO
BEAR. SO I WILL BE LOOKING FOR
THAT PERSONALLY. GREAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
JONES. BOARD MEMBER MCGUIRE.
JUST A COUPLE ITEMS AND THESE
ARE GOING TO BE MORE COMMENTS,
WHAT I HAVE APPRECIATED IS THAT,
AS YOU KNOW, THE RUSSIAN RIVER
BASIN HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MORE
CHALLENGED, AND HAS RECEIVED A
LOT OF ATTENTION, ONE FOR THE
NEED FOR MUNICIPAL SUPPLY, BUT
THEN ALSO OBVIOUSLY FOR
AGRICULTURE, FOCUSING ON
VITICULTURE, AND WHAT I'VE
APPRECIATED IS THAT CHAIR
ESQUIVEL HAS MADE HIS, TIME
AVAILABLE, ESPECIALLY TO GROWERS
ON HOW TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY, AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE GOING
THROUGH SOME OF THE MORE
CHALLENGING TIMES, I WOULD SAY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES, BECAUSE JUST BEING
REALLY CANDID, SOME OF THE
RULES, REGULATIONS AND LAWS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVANCED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TAKE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO ADJUST TO, WHICH THEN BRINGS
UP MY SECOND PIECE, AND THIS IS
MORE OF A NORTH COAST BOARD, BUT
ALSO THE REGIONAL BOARD, BUT HAS
ALSO C  BEEN WITH SOME OF THE
STATE STAFF, AND THAT'S SEPTIC
TANKS WITHIN THE LOWER RUSSIAN
RIVER, AND YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
POORER COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE
LOWER RUSSIAN RIVER. COULD BE
FORESTVILLE, MONO, RIO, RIO
NIDO, GOING THROUGH GUERNEVILLE,
ETC, AND AGING AND, SOME
CHALLENGES IN REGARDS TO NITRATE
LEVELS WITHIN THE LOWER RUSSIAN
AND, AND WHILE THERE NEEDS TO BE
A LONG TERM SOLUTION, THÀNH IS
BEING CANDID. A QUICK FIX SIMPLY
IS NOT GOING TO WORK BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE A SHOCK TO THE
SYSTEM. AND I THINK CREATE MORE
CHALLENGES THAN ACTUAL
SOLUTIONS, I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THAT DOWN AS A MARKER, BECAUSE
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TRACKING VERY CLOSELY. AND
AGAIN, A LOT OF THE WORK IS
BEING DONE AT THE REGIONAL BOARD
LEVEL, BUT KNOW THAT THIS HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE FOR THE STATE
BOARD AS WELL. IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT, GREAT. WELCOME THAT. I
JUST I THANK YOU FOR THAT
COMMENT. AND IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
I'VE BEEN TRACKING VERY CLOSELY
AS WELL. YEAH. MORE TO COME,
MORE TO COME. YEAH. YES. AND I
THINK BIG PICTURE IS, BEING ABLE
TO ASSIST RESIDENCES WITH WHAT
THAT TRANSITION LOOKS LIKE, AND
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK AT SOME TYPE OF
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP FUND,
THAT TRANSITION, WHETHER IT'S
NEW SEPTIC AND OR SYSTEM OF
PLUGGING INTO A CURRENT
WASTEWATER DISTRICT. SO THAT'S
IT TAKES SOME TIME. I AGREE, AND
I THINK I WOULD ALSO SAY WE
REALLY NEED TO BE CONFIDENT IN
THE SCIENCE, THAT THE WATER
QUALITY INFORMATION REALLY
SUPPORTS MOVING FORWARD WITH
THOSE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS. YEAH
THANK YOU. AND YOU MAY BE
HEARING FROM US ON THAT ISSUE
AGAIN AS IT STARTS TO HEAT UP.
YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
BOARD MEMBER. WELL, WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS OPEN IT UP TO
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO, OFFER PUBLIC
COMMENT, HEARING, SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS HERE ON
COMMITTEE WANTING TO BE ABLE TO
BRING FORWARD DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. WE'RE GOING TO ASK THOSE
WE WELCOME YOU ASK THOSE TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP IT TO 30S. WE'LL
GIVE YOU A QUICK PROMPT, FIRST
AND LAST NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.
GOOD AFTERNOON, ROBERT GORE FROM
THE GULKO GROUP, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF SANTA CRUZ,
FRESNO, LONG BEACH, WOODLAND,
ANTIOCH AND WATER DISTRICTS
INCLUDING KINGS RIVER AND
SOQUEL. WATER IS HARD. IT'S
MULTI-LAYERED. IT'S PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST PERMANENT CRITICAL
ISSUES. THERE IS NO BETTER SET
OF EARS, HEART AND MIND THAN
SEAN MCGUIRE. WE'RE ALL STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF HIM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. HI.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON. TÊ. FLEMING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP, FORMERLY THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN WATER
CONSERVATION COUNCIL, AND WE ARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF BOARD
MEMBER MCGUIRE AND HE'S REALLY
PROVEN TO HAVE BOTH THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND
COLLABORATIVE SKILLS TO TACKLE
THE COMPLEX WATER CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE FACING, ESPECIALLY AS
WE FACE CLIMATE CHANGE. MORE
EXTENSIVE DROUGHTS, MORE INTENSE
FLOODING, A DWINDLING SNOWPACK,
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT BOARD
MEMBER MCGUIRE WILL USE HIS
EXEMPLARY SKILL SET TO HELP US
CREATE A MORE RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME HI. CHELSEA HAYNES,
REGULATORY RELATIONS MANAGER FOR
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE REAPPOINTMENT OF
BOARD MEMBER SEAN MCGUIRE. WE
APPRECIATE THAT BOARD MEMBER
MCGUIRE CONSISTENTLY DIVES INTO
THE TECHNICAL DETAILS OF
REGULATIONS AND PROGRAMS IN
FRONT OF THE BOARD. HE WORKS
HARD TO UNDERSTAND THE DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES OF ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES, AND IS THE TRUE
DEFINITION OF A PUBLIC SERVANT.
HÌNH, THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON, PRO TEM
MCGUIRE AND RESPECTED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M DANIELLE KOCH
WITH RANCHO CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICT AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RANCHO CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICT, STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
CONFIRMATION OF BOARD MEMBER
SEAN MCGUIRE TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. BOARD
MEMBER MCGUIRE IS A THOUGHTFUL
AND DELIBERATE AND FAIR
REGULATOR WHO HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ADVANCING CRITICAL
INITIATIVES, INCLUDING DIRECT
POTABLE REUSE, SAFE AND RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER, AND MOVING ON TO
SAFE AND RELIABLE WASTEWATER
INITIATIVES AND MANY OTHERS
WHILE MAKING THE STATE WHILE
MOVING THE STATE FORWARD TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL CALIFORNIA
WATER ISSUES, BOARD MEMBER
MCGUIRE LISTENS TO THE INPUT OF
ALL THOSE ACROSS THE SPECTRUM ON
ISSUES OF CONCERN AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT HIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, ROSARIO CORTEZ, WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF BOARD MEMBER
MCGUIRE'S REAPPOINTMENT, MOST
RECENTLY, MR. MCGUIRE HELPED
OVERSEE THE ADOPTION OF THE
DIRECT POTABLE REUSE REGULATIONS
AND FOR THOSE TWO YEARS, THERE
WAS A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
. AND HE WAS A VERY INSTRUMENTAL
IN ENSURING THAT WATER BOARD
STAFF AND LOCAL AGENCIES HAD AN
OPPORTUNE REYES TO JUST HAVE A
REALLY OPEN PUBLIC PROCESS AND
WE'RE REALLY THANKFUL FOR THAT,
THAT THOSE REGULATIONS WILL
REALLY BECOME A MODEL FOR THE
NATION AND REALLY THE WORLD, WE
THANK MR. MCGUIRE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON ALL TYPES OF
RECYCLED WATER AND WE REALLY
FULLY SUPPORT HIS REAPPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M TODD MANLEY. I'M WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION, AND I'M HERE
HAPPILY TO SUPPORT, MR.
MCGUIRE'S REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. WE'VE REALLY APPRECIATED
WORKING WITH MR. MCGUIRE OVER
THE YEARS. AND HIS SOUND AND
BALANCED APPROACH AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT HE HAS DISPLAYED
ON THE BOARD. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, ERIC ORELLANA
HERE, ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER, I SERVE AS A
SENIOR ADVISORY GROUP MEMBER
WHICH DIRECTS THE $130 MILLION
INVESTMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE INTO SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER, I REPRESENT
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER, A
COMMUNITY BASED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION WORKING TO
ADVANCE SOLUTIONS FOR THE NEARLY
1 MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH UNSAFE DRINKING WATER,
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MR. MCGUIRE'S REAPPOINTMENT.
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD, MR. MCGUIRE'S LEADERSHIP
ON ADVANCING AND DEVELOPING THE
RACIAL EQUITY ACTION PLAN,
ADVANCING, PROMOTING
TRANSPARENCY AND THEN ADVANCING
DRINKING WATER PROJECTS, IS
CRITICAL AND SUPER IMPORTANT AS
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
RELEASED A DRAFT, NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, WHICH IDENTIFIES
MORE THAN $10 BILLION, $10
BILLION NEEDS IN DRINKING WATER
INVESTMENTS. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE LEADERSHIP
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE MINER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STORMWATER QUALITY ASSOCIATION,
CÁC AND SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT, WE'LL JUST THROW IN A
FEW ADDITIONAL ADJECTIVES TO
EVERYTHING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID, WE FOUND BOARD MEMBER
MCGUIRE TO BE VERY COLLABORATIVE
, DELIBERATIVE, ENGAGED,
INFORMED, THOUGHTFUL, FOCUSED ON
SOLUTIONS, ABLE TO INTEGRATE
VERY COMPLEX INFORMATION AND
IDENTIFY THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ANSWERED. AND WE JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE HIS LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US. YES, SIR. MY
NAME IS JOE GARCIA, AND I'M A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE CITY
OF ESCONDIDO. AND AS A LOCAL
JURISDICTION, WE HAVE INVESTED A
LOT A LOT OF TAXPAYER MONEY INTO
A WATER RECYCLED PROGRAM. AND
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
SPECIFICALLY DEVELOPED TO HELP
THE FARMERS, WHICH ARE SUFFERING
INCREDIBLY IN SAN DIEGO. SO I
WOULD MINE IS MORE OF A COMMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
STATE CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS TO CREATE CREATIVE
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PARTNERSHIP TO HELP OUR
CONSTITUENTS, TO HELP OUR
COUNTRY, TO HELP OUR, OUR OUR
STATE. SO ANYWAY, WE'RE WORKING
VERY HARD. WE'VE LOWERED THE
PRICE OF THE WATER FOR THE
FARMERS IN ESCONDIDO,
PARTICULARLY THE AVOCADO FARMERS
. AND I HEAR WONDERFUL THINGS
ABOUT YOU AND I WOULD STAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, COUNCILMAN. APPRECIATE IT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO A FINAL CALL.
LAST CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME HEARING, SEEING NO ONE
STAND, WE'RE GOING TO LOOK FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS
TIME, SEEING NO ONE, WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
ANY FINAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE'LL ALSO WELCOME A MOTION. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. FIRST LET'S GO TO, LEADER
JONES. THANK THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MR. MCGUIRE, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENCE THIS
AFTERNOON. I APPRECIATE IT. I
WAS, COMING IN THIS AFTERNOON ON
KIND OF, LEANING TOWARDS
ABSTAINING ON THE VOTE AND KIND
OF LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING ON
SOME OTHER THINGS. BUT I'VE DONE
SOME RESEARCH, WHILE I'VE BEEN
HERE AND HAVE GOTTEN SOME THUMBS
UP, SOME FROM SOME FOLKS. AND
IMPORTANT CONSTITUENTS IN SAN
DIEGO. YOU HEARD FROM ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS, CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS, I WILL DO MY RESEARCH
ON FIGURING OUT HOW MANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS I RAISED ARE
STILL VALID. AND THEN I'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU
AND HOPEFULLY HAVING A ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT. THANK
YOU. AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU. APOLOGIZE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LEADER JONES. MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR, A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY MR. LAIRD. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE UNCLE.
THAT'S A40 ON CALL. FOUR ZERO ON
CALL. MR. MCGUIRE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE VICE
CHAIR GROVE ADD ON WHEN SHE GETS
BACK FROM HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE
THAT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE
ARE GOING TO BE RECESSING. THE
PUBLIC PORTION OF THE AGENDA AND
GO INTO OUR EXECUTIVE SESSION.
WE'RE GOING TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE TO BE HERE. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A QUICK RECESS TO ALLOW
FOLKS TO FILE OUT OF THE ROOM,
AND WE'LL BE BACK WITH EXECUTIVE
SESSION IN ABOUT 1 TO 2 MINUTES.
ALRIGHT SO WE ARE BACK
FROM RECESS. CURRENTLY THERE IS
ONE APPOINTEE ON CALL
THATS ITEM 1C UNDER GOVERNORS
APPOINTMENTS. THE CURRENT VOTE
FOR ITEM 1C IS 4 TO 0.
MADAME SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE. AYE. GROVE AYE. FIVE TO 0
THATS A FIVE 0 VOTE. THE MOTION
PASSES. WE ARE NOW GOING TO
OFFICIALLY ADJOURN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR JUNE 12.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY. WE'LL SEE
YOU NEXT WEEK.